البدايه مع ما قاله الرئيس الاوكراني
فلودي ميرزيلنسكي لانه عاد الى بلاده
بنتائج جيده من قمه النيتو في ليتو واضاف
انه تم تشكيلهما وصفه بالاساس الامنيه
لاوكرانيا في طريقها الى عضويه الحلف
نعود الى الوطن بنتائج جيده لبلدنا ومهمه
لجنودنا نعود باسلحه جيده ودفاع جوي
وصواريخ وعربات مصفحه ومدفعيه لاول مره
منذ الاستقلال شكلنا اساسا امنيا
لاوكرانيا في طريقنا الى النيتو وهو امر
مهم للغايه هذه ضمانات الامنيه المحدده
اكدتها افضل سبع ديمقراطيات في العالم
ازلنا اي شكوك وغموض حول ما اذا كانت
اوكرانيا ستكون في النيتو سيكون ذلك ولاول
مره
لا حسان مسعود لنبدا معك حسان وتصريحات
زيلينسكي الاخيره
ماذا نقرا فيها
بالفعل ليلى كما ذكرتي الانزعاج الذي
ابداه الرئيس الاوكراني خلال توجهه نحو
ليتوانيا بدا مختلفا هذه المره وبدا الحال
ايضا مختلف بعد عودته اثناء عودته بالقطار
كان قد وجه خطابا طويلا
نسبيا اشار خلاله الى نتائج هذه الزياره
والى قمه الناتو وكذلك قمه مجلس اوروبا
اوكرانيا الناتو اوكرانيا قال ان ما حصل
عليه خلال هذه الزياره كان ايجابيا للغايه
لا سيما فيما يرتبط بالاسلحه التي حصلت
عليها اوكرانيا كان هناك نتائج على مستوى
الحصول على منظومات للدفاع الجوي سواء
كانت منظومات نا سامز او باتريوت بالاضافه
الى الحصول على عدد كبير من الدعم العسكري
والذخائر من مجموعه من الدول الاعضاء في
حلف الناتو قال كذلك ان الدخول الى حلف
الناتو وجود اوكرانيا في هذا الحلف لم يعد
هناك شك فيه قال انه سيقوم بكل الاجراءات
اللازمه على المستوى القانوني وعلى
المستوى العملي لهذا الانضمام وكذلك اشار
الى ان اوكرانيا كانت تنتظر هذه الفرصه من
الحلفاء لكي يقوموا بالتاكيد على ضروره
الضم اوكرانيا الى هذا الحلف اكد ان معظم
الاعضاء يقومون بالضغط من اجل ذلك
بالاضافه ايضا الى اتفاق الجميع على ان
اوكرانيا يجب ان تكون عضوا في الناتو ان
اوكرانيا باتت اقرب من اي وقت مضى وقام
بشكر جميع الدول دوله بعد الاخرى في خطابه
والحديث عن كل تفصيل مما قدموه خلال هذا
اللقاء ولكن لم يكن هذا ما ينتظره
زيلينسكي عندما غادر الى قمه الناتو كان
ينتظر دعوه واضحه من حلف الاطلسي كما قال
لانضمام اوكرانيا الى حلفا الناتو وكان
يطالب بجدول زمني واضح وهذا ما لم يحصل
خلال هذا اللقاء هناك في داخل الاوكرانيه
على مستوى المحللين المتابعين لاشان
الاوكراني ولهذه الزياره جدل بين
المتابعين والمراقبين عما الت اليه هذه
الزياره هناك من لا يخفي الانزعاج من
نتائج هذه القمه وعدم الحصول على ما كانت
تطمح اليه اوكرانيا لاسيما وان هذه القمه
ربما ستقام العام المقبل على الاقل وهو ما
يعني ان اوكرانيا لن تنضم او لن يتم
دعوتها الى هذا الحلف بشكل رسمي طيله هذا
العام وهذا ايضا ربما يشير بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين ولا سيما المنزعجين من هذه
القمه الى ان الحرب ستستمر عام اضافي خلال
هذه الفتره هذه العوده من القمه تزامنت مع
هجمه صاروخيه وبالمسيرات وجهت نحو العاصمه
الاوكرانيه وعدد من المدن الاوكرانيه بشكل
مكثف هذه الليله نعم